all right on Lee on Lee uh where are you
from originally where'd you grow up I am
from the Bay Area and I've been in La
since 2008.
tell me about your family growing up uh
my family's from Taiwan originally they
immigrated in the 80s they went to
college in the states and for grad
school in the states and
then my entire family moved to the Bay
area around the time I was one I was
born in the U.S
um
yeah how would you describe your
childhood
um somewhat privileged I would suppose
uh I
grew up in a middle class to upper
middle class area in the suburbs
um very very high achieving school high
achieving family all my parents have
advanced degrees
I went to a pretty prestigious
University and
my school was super academic just a very
very academic
safe town like safe town
yeah and uh
you've been doing this kind of work for
how long nine years
um yeah I started when I was 23 so nine
years then you're this has been your
career yeah it was I had another career
before this but I wasn't happy with it
quite frankly
um I came from a background in Visual
Arts and then I became a web developer
and well I became background Visual Arts
to graphic design to web development
and the web development was kind of by
way of graphic design because jobs are
just easier to get and
didn't really like it a lot of code a
lot of staring at the computer a lot
less Hands-On and visceral than I
preferred and
yeah one day my friend was like you
should be a Dominatrix and I became one
this is this fits your personality
better yeah
um
whenever well I'm pretty much out to
everyone everyone that I've known since
high school no one is surprised by it
none of my family members are surprised
by it pretty much everyone's like oh
yeah that was kind of kind of the way it
should have been
your clients come
in all shapes and sizes yeah yeah lately
they've been veering younger
I think just by product social media and
maybe
oh yeah I don't actually know why that
is um I have a well you would think you
would have an older yeah I think
that's typically how it is for most sex
workers uh but I think because I have a
pretty large presence on social media a
lot of younger people find me
um but yeah I mean it's the usual mix of
like
upper middle class typically white men
is you know middle aged and then I have
a decent amount of young folks and what
kind of
things will you get into
um so my specialty is what I'm known for
would be bondage full toilet training
and CBT ball busting and caning or
corporal punishment generally yeah I
typically play on the heavier side of
things
um I like to think I'm kind of a very
technical BDSM player yeah
these are guys who probably have good
jobs many of them typically I mean it's
not particularly cheap to see me so one
you know either you have to have a good
job or you have to
have some amount of cash to see me it's
not um it is not particularly a small
Financial commitment on a low budget
yeah I'm not I'm I'm not and these guys
what is it that draws them to wanting to
wanting to be treated the way you treat
them
because they probably have positions a
lot of them have jobs that are we're
there in in control yeah so that's a
that's a very broad question uh the
stereotypical answer would be you know a
lot of these people are in control a lot
of the times in their life and they need
a way to relax
um sometimes people have very specific
fetishes that their Partners can't or
won't
um subscribe to uh sometimes they just
want to try something new um you know
just trying trying something new
sometimes
yeah it's kind of there is never really
one answer for it uh
yeah it it really just depends sometimes
they're just sensory seeking people who
want to try new new things so these are
all male typically
um I see also a lot of afab people I see
a lot of women non-binary people
um I see a lot of trans people uh in the
past couple of years things have been
definitely swinging towards at least for
me more of um any gender any sexuality
might apply which I personally prefer
yeah what is
your I mean how does this affect you
personally your personal life
um so my partner is submissive I met him
not through work but through kind of a
lifestyle play situation I have a lot of
submissives in my life for example I
have a clean slave AKA house [__] and
he's been with me for almost the
entirety of my career
um
it's kind of one-dimensional of me but a
lot of my friends are on the sub-ear
types of things because I have a what
one might call a big personality
um so it tends to work out well with
more submissive types
um
we'll see I mean it's pretty
it's like with any other job right how
much of your job is your personality and
how much of your job leads into your
personal life it really just depends on
how much you let it right but I do love
what I do and so a lot of my job bleeds
into my personal life you know sometimes
to my detriment because work life
balance but uh
yeah I mean it affects me moderately I
suppose
what's the wildest thing that your
clients have asked you to do that's the
stereotypical question yeah there's a
bunch of my questions yeah
um I mean my definition of wild is very
different than other people's definition
of Wilds most of my sessions one might
say are pretty wild because I am a heavy
player so for example I [__] on people a
lot that's wild but I do it all the time
so it's not wild to me for me to this
day one of the weirdest sessions I've
ever done is someone it was like a two
or three hour session when I was a house
job and a house Dom is when you work in
a house of dominatristies you're not
independent yet and the sky
was just really scared of everything and
he wanted me to write three comparative
essays about how weak he was
um using specific keywords in kind of
like a a very Scholastic sort of way it
was very it was to this day still one of
the weirder sessions I've done because
he had a whole list of keywords and you
know like uh photos and it had to be
compare and contrast and the basic gist
of it at the time I was adverse
advertising myself as this like genius
dominatrix with like a genius IQ and
yeah so it was it was a weird session it
was just it was just my hands retired
from writing from writing like six pages
of essays so let me ask you a two-part
question so what do you what do you
think it was about their childhoods that
led them to need this kind of treatment
um so this guy I'd asked him about it
and he came from a very wealthy High
achieving immigrant family
um he was Korean and his family was very
very successful
and so he kind of had a lot of he was a
trust fund baby
um but he didn't really achieve much in
his life and he had really overbearing
parents who were constantly really hard
on him academically
um and then he moved to the U.S where he
was a small Asian guy and he got made
fun of a lot for being just kind of a
shrimpy dude trying to be athletic um so
it was a lot of you know traumas in his
childhood that he tend to sexualize
um I think I personally think that
that's a lot of people is uh you know
you have certain either traumas or just
like random incidents in your childhood
that you sexualize there is this whole
kind of theory of that's not what it is
um but from my experience I know a lot
of my clients can tie it down to oh I
saw a Catwoman in on TV and you know at
the same time I got my first boner and
now I associate with being with sexiness
um
yeah some people just don't know though
um you know uh yeah so I want to say
like
a mix of you know trauma
sexualizing your traumas and then just
like associating your
your first memories of arousal with
whatever was happening at the time
um
yeah and sometimes people just need
sensory kind of stimulation you know
normal sex isn't enough or maybe they're
asexual
um do you think there's a lot more of
this going on than
then we all assume it there I think so
yeah I personally think so I mean given
I have like uh you're in the front lines
of it yeah I have a very skewed view of
it um I think more often than not most
people are have some kind of Kink it's
to what extent they admit it or allow it
or really want to explore it
um but for example most women I know
are like afab people you know most of us
have some kind of Kinks going on um just
based solely on
what media has taught us is supposed to
be sexy
um yeah I think it's a lot more common
than people might think and especially a
lot of men might be in denial about it
because
you know when I try to explain my job to
people like I'm a dominatrix I beat
people up I bully them I like sometimes
I humiliate them you know I do all these
things and people were like but why
would anyone like that and I'm like
well think about
as say you're a man and this woman comes
on really strong to you and she knows
exactly what she wants and what she
wants to do to you is that not sexy you
know to have like a certain kind of
confidence and that confidence can be
brought in all sorts of different fields
just to even know what you want right
um so that's kind of how I Define
domination as a general whole is
um like an afab leaning person who you
know
knows what they want and knows what
they're going to do about it and being
part of that question is what is it
about your childhood that led you to
you're a Dom you're a dominatrist you're
a dominant yes what made you that way
um probably my grandma my grandma's very
very matriarchal it's um when I think
about every one on my father's side of
the family all the all the women on my
father's side of the family are very
bossy um there's just no way around it
we're all just very bossy because it's
your personality yeah I've been a bossy
person since I was a kid all my cousins
are bossy people
um and some guys are turned on by that
yes and it's I've definitely noticed it
since I was way too young you know like
you have when you're a bossy bossy girl
growing up you always have a couple of
boys who just follow you around because
you're bossy and it was something that I
have come to accept it was kind of how I
played with others uh yeah and then
there's also you know I'ma say this just
because probably because of Jackass and
like America's funniest videos because
it's just really funny to me you know I
was um watching jackass
the the latest one and it all just like
clicked to me I was like oh this is this
is easily 50 of my humor is just like
prepubescent 13 year old boy humor so
yeah I think this is what makes the
world go around for some people you're
your personality would not work for them
yes but for somebody else you're exactly
what they want yes yeah that's what
makes life interesting yeah absolutely I
think these these fetishes that some of
us have or maybe maybe most of us have
I think I think if we just eased up our
attitudes about it we could all just
enjoy ourselves more yeah definitely and
extreme denial of their fetishes maybe
their partner doesn't want it so they're
trying really hard to be vanilla normal
normal
um and what I always see consistently
pretty much time after time after time
is the more you deny it the stronger the
need comes
um
and you know I've seen I don't
necessarily believe in sex addiction as
a whole I mostly believe in like some
people some people have addictive
qualities about them but something that
does create an addictive quality in my
opinion is just the constant denial of
something to the point where you really
need it you know it's constantly on your
mind because you're denying yourself
it's like a binge Purge cycle so it's
probably better for everyone if we just
accept who we are yeah
and you you prefer somebody who's
submissive generally yes
um you know I have a lot of proton
friends the pro Dom Community is pretty
tight-knit
um but if a guy came into your life and
you're single and looking and he was
very dominant that would hate it hate it
hate it like it's it's there's something
deeply repulsive about it whereas for
some women that's that's a turnout yeah
yeah I just I can't if I have to be
honest I have a hard time taking men
seriously a lot of times
um because I just
I just do what what have you learned
about men from this kind of work I think
men are more easily scared than you
might think they are and also they're a
lot easier to boss around than you might
think they are but I also knew that as a
young kid you know because it's what
I've been doing since I was a child it's
pretty much how I interface with males
so some men enjoy that yes they do and
they thrive on it um there's so many
different types of domination whether
it's Financial or physical or yeah you
know so many things yeah definitely
um yeah and it's uh it's worked out well
for me
you enjoy your work I love it yeah
um I feel
becoming a dominatrix was one of the top
two best choices I made in my life is it
ever sexual it can be
um but professionally for me not really
um I don't really play in the more
sensual types of fields I do you know I
do kind of I do porn
um uh but I don't never do penetrative
porn on my end I'm just not interested
in it I have dabbled in you know full
service types of stuff very very early
on in my career and it was not for me
um is it ever sexual for your clients oh
yeah absolutely it's probably always
sexual for you it's not always sexual
like you know sometimes I'll have people
just clean clean the dungeon you know
and is that sexual I mean it could be
afterwards they're probably jerking off
to it
um but then for example there's also
Chastity which is kind of the opposite
of sexual where you can't even have a
boner right so sometimes it's sexual
sometimes it isn't sometimes it's just a
sensory experience for them like being
in bondage or something I mean
oftentimes on just sexual for people but
what do you think we all need to
understand that we perhaps most of us do
not
um
you probably have some interesting
insights that many of us don't have oh
man that's such a broad question I'm
drawing a blank right now
ah I think
I think human sexuality is I mean this
is this is a broad empty answer but I
think human sexuality is pretty complex
and
it's hard to assign
causality to it
um sometimes you just have to let it be
and accept that it is there I see a lot
of people being very repressive about
their sexuality and I think that's
honestly one of the worst things that
you can do for it
um you kind of just have to let it be
and
accept that or else it's just gonna get
weirder and weirder and more compulsive
and addictive for you
um
at the same time there's a balance to
everything right
um it's a world that many of us
don't even know exists yeah
and it probably exists much more oh yeah
like um around here not in Skid Row but
uh you know within half a mile of here
there are at least five dungeons right
you know and um there's there's there's
loads of them and they're actually quite
nice places
and the client the people that go there
are not
demented and no and on drugs and all
that some of them are but I'm sure yeah
um so they're not I think it really
depends on how you screen people uh are
drugs a big thing in your line of work
so not for me personally I do a lot of
heavy screening
um I
when I was younger and not independent
and didn't wasn't doing my own screening
I certainly came across a decent amount
of drug use
um but for my own safety and for my own
preferences and the types of clients I
like
a you know I prefer people to be
relatively sober in our sessions like
fun have a drink before smoke a little
weed but like do not be hot like do not
be out of your mind especially for our
first scene
um
yeah I do know that it was different in
the 80s and 90s though where dungeons
were kind of like drug dense but I don't
believe it's really that way now unless
you go to different types of dungeons
um I mean there's there's room for all
sorts within sex work really
is there any advice you would give
a woman who's single and out there
you know you know dating and whatever
there's things that she probably could
use that that you've learned
um I think the thing that most people
lack is consent uh being able to discuss
consent
um I know for me personally uh probably
one of the things that I've really
learned and gotten familiar with was
being able to discuss consent
um I think especially when you're raised
as a woman in the society you kind of
learn just to take whatever sexual
advances come your way right um you're
lucky to have it you know it's just a
compliment uh you know you look at porn
and they're getting pushed around and
you know the there's rough play and
stuff like that which is which is
totally fine if you discuss it but I
think a lot of people fail to discuss
these things before they engage in
sexual activity
um the thing the thing about BDSM
relationships is there's a lot more
agreement on
what we want what we what we enjoy and
what we don't like whereas when you go
into a conventional relationship
conventional like I don't know
conventional hetero relationship it's
kind of like oh yeah well then you're
gonna how explicit can I be on here you
say whatever you like okay like you're
gonna suck my dick and then like maybe I
want to [__] you in the ass and like you
know we'll talk about it like we'll talk
about it afterwards but mostly like I'm
gonna come first and then you know we'll
we'll see you know there's
given that's that's a terrible
stereotype I know not everyone is like
that but I've never had more consent
violations than I have with within my
vanilla relationships whereas within my
BDSM relationships we have talked in
detail about
what we like what we want what we don't
like and I think vanilla relationships
really
you should do that because it's sexy to
be able to talk about consent and
certainly a lot sexier than feeling
assaulted that's what I've seen from a
lot of the fetish people that I've
interviewed is because the communication
is incredibly good yes and it should be
like that in everything it shouldn't
just be like that because we're engaging
in Alternatives
in every aspect of it yeah
I think it just it moves us all forward
yeah definitely in a better way
definitely
and it's also kind of foolish to assume
that we all want the same things just
because they're presented a certain way
in popular media
um obviously I don't want the same
things as every everyone else you know
um it's a really it's an easy when
communication is great it's an easier
way of finding out what your into and
what your partner's into and yeah you
guys are good match and maybe you're not
yeah and you know um so for example my
current partner he was married before me
and a long decade-long marriage and he
only really came out to her about his
predilections maybe halfway through the
marriage and they attempted it and that
was part of the downfall of their
relationship was just this complete
incompatibility in the bedroom
um I've also talked to loads of my
clients and friends and where it's stuff
like they went into a relationship
thinking that somewhere along the way
that communication would get hashed out
and they would have an understanding
but you know you go into the
relationship with two different ideas in
mind and then halfway through you
realize you don't really know each other
um so I think it's important that we all
be very very
upfront with who we are what we want
what we need
in a relationship right off the bats are
fetishes
Ever Changing or are they pretty much
what they are and you stick with that
for the rest of your oh they're
absolutely changing I mean some people
for some people it very much sticks to
what it is I see that typically more
commonly in males
um where their fetishes tend to be kind
of
like set in stone but for me you know I
came into this with
not as many fetishes as I have now I
just you know [__] just keeps on
changing
um I'm also very sensory seeking person
so I need new things
um it's part of why I do this is you
know to fulfill that sensory need uh so
yeah it absolutely changes
um yeah are some of your clients married
and their wives probably just don't give
them what they need yeah and they've
made an agreement or maybe they're
sneaking out and getting what they need
I mean I think that's with all of sex
work right as uh oftentimes it's uh you
know clients and unhappy relationships I
think it's also unfair to put the onus
on the relationship too because
sometimes it's just dudes being sheisty
um but also I've met the wives of some
of my clients uh you know some of my
clients their Partners fully know about
me
um I it's getting a little bit more
common especially with the younger crowd
uh because they tend to be a little bit
more open-minded about this
but
um yeah I mean the stereotypical story
is that like yeah the needs aren't
getting met at home and therefore
they're doing that but sometimes the
needs are getting met and sometimes
people just impulsively need new things
or maybe sometimes someone's on vacation
and or like on a work trip and they're
just bored you know um
it's it's all kinds of reasons but I
think people would be surprised by
knowing the number of clients that I
have where their Partners know me
um especially because I provide a very
specific sort of skill that the Layman
absolutely cannot provide because I've
spent years honing it like you know
using a bull whip or you know tying
someone up in a very specific way you're
not going to pick that up right off the
bat you need to see a professional about
it or even needleplay any kind of blood
play any kind of medical play yeah
is there anything else you'd like to
talk about
um
so there is something I I would like to
talk about so I've seen a lot of your
work online and I think part of maybe
it's by proxy of you know your location
but the frustrating thing for me
watching your video sometimes is there's
a bit of a Save A Hoe mentality
um like
given a lot of these people are survival
workers and stuff like that but there
are plenty of people who do this because
we want to and given I'm coming from a
point of privilege to be able to do this
like I can pick and choose the clients I
want I work in a relatively safe
environment you know I make a lot of
money
um but
sometimes reading the comments of
your videos frustrates me because it's
like oh these people are just I don't
know it's it's a little
like sometimes people actually do want
to do sex work you know it's not there
are some women that are just they're
wired to do this yeah and you know
Square job just doesn't fit yeah and I I
have done the square jobs and I fully am
qualified to do the square jobs I come
from like a high high achieving
background and yet I chose to be a hoe
you know I chose I chose to do this
stuff in part because it makes me happy
um and I think that's a lot something
that a lot of people don't understand is
that there are indeed some of us in sex
work who really love it who really
thrive in it
um it's not me running away from my
problems or like you know being
compulsive about something it's perhaps
me facing my problems directly up front
and
yeah I don't know
um
yeah I just wanted I wanted yeah no
that's a great point and I as I've been
doing these talks I've learned that that
is the case very often yeah that some
women are and then are just
this is what they do best yeah this is
what makes them happy yeah they don't
need to be changed they don't need to be
fixed yeah
and you know I think in another lifetime
I probably still would have been a
dominatrix I just I just would have
because it's you know when I think about
everything that has led up to this point
it all makes a lot of sense why I do
what I do
um and it makes me remarkably happy I
just can't think of another job that
would be quite as fulfilling that gives
me as much Freedom as this given it
hasn't always been like that I had to
work pretty hard to get to this place
but you know now that I'm here I'm I'm
pretty happy that I'm here you know yeah
I think my goal in creating and sharing
these videos is to learn yeah for me and
and my audience I think enjoys learning
and we discover new things about each
other and
I think it helps move Society forward a
little bit yeah
yeah and given I'm still like being a
sex worker is still a pretty
disenfranchising part of society you
know a lot of people make assumptions
about who you are I think you know the
standard like oh comes from a broken
family lots of drug use is just like you
know an irreparable person
um sort of stuff uh you know those
people exist in pretty much all Realms
of the world down to like your Walmart
cashier to your [__] sea level I
don't know Fortune Fortune 500 company
um
I don't think sex work inherently
necessarily draws the worst of the worst
or the the saddest or the saddest or the
most pitiable of the pitiable
um but oftentimes it does create a very
necessary source of revenue for people
who wouldn't be able to make it
elsewhere
um
I'm lucky in that
you know I I could have made my Revenue
elsewhere very very comfortably but I
chose to do this despite all that even
even knowing that you know a lot of
people looked down on me
um and even knowing that the banks could
shut down my bank accounts at any moment
and I'm constantly getting you know
censored all over the place uh there's
always judgment with this kind of work
isn't it yeah it's better in La though
amongst um entertainment types but you
know you go out of LA to a couple more
Suburban types since it's a little
different
[Music]
and Lee what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned
um
experience you've had
I think I have a lot more sympathy for
people now
um
I feel a side of people that most people
don't see and I'm very intimately
familiar with it
um and generally I would not say I'm the
most empathetic person
um tend to be a little bit robotic in
things tend to be really black and white
about everything uh but I think this job
has allowed me an inside Peak into other
people's mentalities and where they are
in life and I'm pretty grateful for that
like I was oftentimes the first person
someone came out to when they announced
they were trans or gay or you know
I I was the first person when one of my
Subs told me that they were going to
divorce their wife you know
um I am privy to a lot of Secrets of
people which has always kind of been the
case I think a lot of people who become
dominatristies were always the type of
person that people feel like they can
trust their deepest darkest Secrets
around
um
but doing this on a pretty much
professional level is uh has
yeah given me a bit more empathy for
people you know
that's great
all right I'm Lee thank you so much for
sharing your story
refreshing to meet somebody who's happy
ah in this line of work so instead of
having regrets and yeah miserable yeah
for sure thank you very much